speaking of Bernie Sanders I he's the
one that makes their heads explode when
he took and to proof of that I want to
show you Donald Trump I mentioned this
in the monologue talking about Bernie
the next day cuz this maniac that was
standing on a right is giving everything
away so she's following that's what's
happening this socialist-slash-communist
he's going to tax you people at 90
percents going to take everything I said
I said I said 80% okay so this halfway
point that what happens is Bernie says
something they hear something completely
again so so what we did is we put up
there a little video package for you
these are you'll hear what Bernie
actually said and then you will hear
what the Republicans heard on the use of
force Bernie said I supported President
Clinton's effort the deal with ethnic
cleansing in Kosovo and the Republicans
heard I will refocus our military on
gardening and interpretive dance
we must aspire to the fighting style of
the Iraqi army tear off your uniforms
and run on American exceptionalism
Bernie said and I think we should look
to countries like Denmark like Sweden
and Norway and they're from what they
have accomplished and they heard I will
not rest until every single American is
driving a little car with three
times you will watch soccer and you will
like it
this is what Bernie actually said on
guns let's begin Anderson by
understanding but the Bernie Sanders has
a d-minus voting record from the NRA and
this is what they heard let's begin
Anderson by understanding that rifles
offer men with small penises every
single gun in this country should be
confiscated and melted down to make Tony
Awards they're not hearing it on the
military Bernie said when I was a young
man I strongly opposed the war in
Vietnam and this is whether Republicans
heard I would have loved to fight in
Vietnam but for the other side not only
do I hate our troops but sometimes I
walk John McCain in his office to a
Vietnamese accent and left
and finally on the war on drugs Bernie
said I think we have to think through
this war on drugs which has done an
enormous amount of damage and the
Republicans heard
I majored in Sharia law at the
University of Havana and I know this it
is a moral catastrophe that we are the
only major country in the world that
doesn't sell marijuana to children black
lives not only matter they are all that
matters
die whitey die
you